so
so
[Music]
[Applause]
happy week 15 everybody hope you got
your sleep like tyron woodley did
because it's nfl sunday baby let's go
you just tapped into the br vetting
squad ride
live in the bleacher report out
presented by draftkings i'm connor
rogers alongside the man that was at the
fight last night greg how are you
feeling today man what's going on
feeling good connor feeling really good
feeling so good in fact i'm giving away
hoodies to the people in the comments
right now i got jonathan 2x72
jonathan 2x72
says micah parsons all day riding with
micah parsons for defensive player of
the year uh hey you are walking away
with a hoodie
we're getting in that we're getting into
that at some point but you know what we
got to start with we're looking for
those touchdown scores we ask you in the
app we ask you on social we do this
every week who is your lock to get in
the end zone it is the fantasy playoffs
as well so everybody's got extra eyes on
this greg let's take a look at who you
sent us this week the top odds to score
a touchdown james connor at the top he's
been a workhorse for arizona but don't
forget chase edmonds will be activated
off ir this week leonard fournette
regular season lenny not just playoff
lenny anymore ezekiel elliott against
the banged up giants devonte adams joe
mixon stefan diggs who has not scored
the last two weeks gonna be interesting
to keep an eye on him quarter out
patterson who might be the reason most
of you made it to the fantasy playoffs
thanks to his waiver wire pickup this
year
and then deontay foreman right there as
well kind of our dark horse one on this
board so
with that being said an interesting
board this week before we get into the
squad ride competition i'll show you the
lock legend videos from last week that
we did not get to show on our program
my pick to score a touchdown this
weekend we might as well make it
profitable
[Music]
[Music]
this is smart chase anytime touchdown
score lock it in baby
all right greg let him know what we got
going on this week
all right man all right we are giving
away two not one but two nfl jersey gift
card that means somebody
in this comment somebody that is
watching right now is walking away with
a jersey and also the winner of the lock
legend contest is walking away in with a
jersey so what i need you guys to do is
get in the comments i need gifts i need
emojis i need locks i need winners i
need takes i need you guys to just fill
those comments up
but most importantly fill them up with
winners only please
thank you you heard the man winners only
please help him out help us out fill
that comment section today let's get
into the lock legend tournament who is
going to be the squad ride leader who's
taking home that title who's taking home
that jersey and what odds is greg
boosting this week in draftkings to
score a touchdown the first one
from pro angler jb a familiar face who's
scoring a touchdown this week pro angler
what's up br betting so this year
instead of sending santa my christmas
letter i asked him for a lock
there we go james connor minus 190.
the santa lock legend going with james
connor at minus 190 but you can do
something with those odds don't fear
those just yet our first competition
of the day though we got tyler carbone
here to challenge jb let's see that
selection
hey b our bet and we gotta lock for a
deontay form and touchdown so we're
gonna do some snow angels because we're
praying for it
let's go
deontay foreman the snow angel lock
legend deante foreman plus 150 greg i
like that that's we love that plus money
on this show we got james connor santa
claus sending that one we got deontay
foreman from the snow angel legend greg
first off what do we need and how are we
feeling about these
well first off i need everybody in the
comments to let us know let me know let
connor know which way are we riding are
we riding with james connor
are we riding with hunter foreman um
i'm actually i don't know which way i
want to ride with this one i know we do
know the impact of james connor carter
we do know the impact of him uh edmunds
edmonds the other back in arizona is
coming back today is this gonna affect
james connor touches i don't know and
it's him sitting at -190 connor that is
a lot of juice
now don't be alarmed you guys know what
we can do here on the squad right that's
a lot of juice if if i'm being honest
that's a lot of juice so honestly i i
don't know and then with foreman
tennessee they have another back hail
yard for like
it's just too much up in the air uh i'm
gonna rock well what the people are
rocking with connor which way are you
leaning yeah i'm gonna defer to the
people too i'll say that i'll leave you
with this like you said greg chase
edmonds is coming back and they're not
just gonna you know completely work him
into the point of no return but they
need him involved to get ready for the
playoffs as great as james connor has
been one of the best value free agency
signings of this off-season they need
that two-back system they need chase
edmonds the pass catcher to get involved
they're gonna ramp up his workload which
has to scare you a little bit and at
some point james connor needs a little
bit of a break as well deontay foreman
greg is just hit or miss right now right
obviously there's a lot going on in that
backfield like you said so
i will defer to james connor because of
what he can do on the goal line but this
is a tough selection we're gonna we're
gonna call the comments to solve this
one
yeah i'm in the comments right now uh if
you guys don't know the new people to
the show this right here is the handy
dandy ipad this is how you win your
hoodies how you win your jerseys
this is just this is how you get tapped
in uh i see
manual says
phx1 says winter wonderland foreman is a
lock wow like that uh
james connor easy touchdown machine with
or without admins
k pods uh says that shout out to you
k-pops you're walking away with hoodie
connor they're back and forth in the
comments i got brandon bostrom says
connor
i got maxwell rexel in the comments
saying foreman uh i'm gonna make a
decision here connor i'm just gonna make
a decision i'm just gonna slide
bam oh i got zach zwiebel says
foreman so we're going to rock
performing we're going to rock with my
guy dante foreman moving on to the next
round the plus money uh snow angels
tyler
you you all are moving on to the next
round diante foreman the underdog taking
round one and at that kind of plus money
plus 150 greg's going to be able to get
that at least into the 200s so a lot of
fun to work with that one we're not done
we got two more challengers to go here
this thing is far from over and the next
challenger goes by the name of marshall
mcgaw let's see that week 15 touchdown
score marshall
what's up beer betting i'm out here
today with my partner looking for this
week's lock let's go
you finally found it
let's dig it up
look what we dug up
stefan diggs anytime touchdown score
lock it in
they don't call them labrador retrievers
for nothing retrieving the lock of the
week is stefan diggs from the hunting
legend greg this has been kind of a
low-key favorite of ours on the squad
ride throughout the entire season stefan
diggs and he hasn't found the end zone
the last two weeks which means he's
kinda do let's not forget he caught five
touchdowns in a three-week span before
that deante foreman clearly got some
juices the underdog from last round
a little tougher of a match up here
right
oh yeah i'm all over you mentioned it
we've been on stefan diggs we've been
josh allen fans we've been on the bills
a lot during this show uh
and i'm still gonna rock with my guy
stefan dix he's plus money i like this
plus money more than the free the
foreman plus money i'll be honest uh the
reason why connor we talk about it all
the time i got josh allen stefan diggs
is his number one receiver he loves to
feed stefan dix honestly it might be the
reason he's in his slump right now he's
in a little slump right now and it might
be b because he's trying to force feed
stephon dix but that's one thing we know
that he's gonna do feed stefan diggs so
i'm gonna rock with stefan diggs here
and you guys know what we're going to do
to that plus 110 uh
connor which way are you leaning are you
rocking with stefan diggs are you still
thinking uh
i'm going with diggs right number one
i'm surprised this is plus money i
thought this would be around minus 110
and maybe even even so plus 110 helps a
little bit here and let's not forget you
said it a true number one wide receiver
for josh allen stefan dix has gotten
double-digit targets in six games this
year when the bills need a first down or
a touchdown or a big play
they look one way and it's stefan diggs
right you just can't say that about
deontay foreman i'm sorry he's been a
nice storyline this year but you go with
what works you go with what's made you
money in the past so your riding digs
i'm riding diggs are the comments taking
digs to the final round of this squad
ride challenge
i got
rtm17 says diggs and robinson they're
sprinkling two
plays in there but they got our guys
stefan dick shout out to you ryan you're
walking away with a hoodie ben yemen ben
yamman says uh
his username has been the goat one two
three says a hundred percent let's go
digs
um shout out to you ben
uh and and i'll leave it at that we'll
just give away two hoodies right here
i'm going with stefan digg yeah there's
no need for more we know what we know
connor we know what you want to do we
know what i want to do and it's clear as
cut it's clear as day in the comments we
know what they want to do so we're just
going to rock with stefan diggs and uh
let's keep this thing going a blowout in
round number two i'm sorry deontay
foreman fans but this is stefan diggs to
lose here round three
final round winner takes home nfl jersey
gift card squad ride leader the title
and their touchdown scorer gets boosted
so if they were betting them anyway go
back in there and get the boosted odds
all right aaron g
whales
you have enough to knock staphon digs
off the leaderboard here let's see it
oh all right real quick diggs or zeke
elliott no questions who are you taking
anytime touchdown score
good all i need to hear glad you're
informed
i don't know if that really sounded like
santa claus there but we're gonna say
santa on the hotline going with ezekiel
elliott don't let the minus money scare
you minus 140. greg's gonna find a way
to get that on the right side of things
we still like diggs we always really
like zeke although he's been banged up
this year and they got to watch his
touches
final round here greg give me your
thoughts
yeah this one's this one's actually
pretty tough connor this one's tough we
got stefan diggs we just talked about
him we just talked about what he the
impact that he is on that buffalo bill
team and what his quarterback tries to
do he tries to find him and he tries to
find him often
but then we got ezekiel elliott here in
a division matchup against the giants
where zeke usually shows up in these
matchups conor in these division
matchups zeke shows up so i
i don't know man i i don't know zeke's
sitting at minus 140 you know what we
can do
i i i'll play it out connor this is what
i'll see happen i see the i see the
cowboys getting inside the five and you
know when they they're inside the five
you know what you're going to get a
heavy deuce of a heavy dose of i'm sorry
you're going to get a heavy dose of
ezekiel elliott so
i think i want a lean zeke but i also
want to sprinkle something about stefan
dix bro i'm so confused right now i'ma
lean with the people i'ma lean with the
comments connor but which way are you
riding which way are you leaning yeah i
wouldn't be mad with either of these
picks this is not a week where we've had
the cooper cup weeks we've had the
jonathan taylor weeks we're begging you
please take these guys they are going to
score nick chubb has been a squad ride
leader and a scorer before this one you
feel good either way i'll leave you with
this greg is spot on division game
division games you go with what you know
and for dallas for the last five years
that's been ezekiel elliott number two
i'm sorry right now the giants are a
sorry you know what team greg i mean i
got on your ig story last week and was
like chargers 10 chargers 9 don't care
they don't have their starting
quarterback mike lennon's turnover prone
that's going to lead to a lot of easy
possessions starting on the right side
of the field and easy touchdown runs the
only thing i have questions for with
zeke is he's been playing hurt is this a
game where they're like we know we got
this in the bag let's manage his
workload but that's overthinking here so
let's let the comments take us home
right now are they riding with us let's
let the comments riding with dicks
so let the comments take us home i got a
manual is back in the comments phx one
he said zeke will eat up the giants
shout out to you manuel you already have
a hoodie uh elliott king fast ellie king
fast king fast has uh
he
he has the the the vikings celebrating
in the end zone so he's rocking with
stephon dix shout out to you elliott i
got joseph uh joseph
joseph magnana it says
santa deniers pick will like the pig
digs
not zeke so i'm
assuming that they're saying that santa
should have chose diggs and not zeke
shout out to you joseph uh i got one
more i got one more
uh
manual mate was back in the comments
manuel's just in the comments today he's
riding with zeke oh no one more here we
go down the earth down earth sand digs
into the sunset hunting legends shout
out to you down there
they're all rocking with stefan diggs
but i'm going to make a decision
call it i i'm gonna make a decision
kanye
people were always saying fay greg fay
greg
greg never wins so guess what
i'm fading the comments they're all
rocking with stefan diggs we're rocking
with ezekiel elliott today we're rocking
with ezekiel elliott i'm giving you guys
a little taste of of you guys treatment
that you guys send to me i'm giving it
back to you and we are rocking with
ezekiel elliott to score a touchdown
today let's pull up
the graphics so i can show you guys some
magic because you guys see ezekiel
elliott is sitting at -140 right there
poof look at that it's not
140 anymore it's now up to plus 120
thanks to our friends at draftkings for
boosting that for us make sure you guys
check us out on all the socials for
links to the odds boost send us your
screenshots of your bets send us your
videos and your celebrations but most
importantly
most importantly guys we want winners
and winners only
please nothing else
man i am so here for the greg keel turn
right now he's had enough of y'all
enough of the bs enough for the trolling
he said i'm picking the squad ride you
can put your money on plus 110 digs or
we can boost zeke to plus 120. so shout
out to aaron g wales you are the squad
ride the leader and shout out to greg
for making the decision it's the first
time we didn't lean on the comments the
full time had a little fun with it
speaking of those comments we got more
locks we got more hoodies you got
another jersey gift card to give away
jersey of anyone's choice so the
community comment contest time this is
the winner takes the hoodie we asked you
a pretty simple one this week in the br
betting community stream in the bleacher
report app you had a hundred dollars to
put on defensive player of the year
defensive player of the year
who are you putting it on let's take a
look at the odds leaders here so far
miles garrett and tj watt at the top
micah parsons is surging into this right
now he has the defensive rookie of the
year race locked up he is surging into
the defensive player of the year odds
then aaron donald truman dig sorry for
the dbs digs and jc jackson you guys
just don't really get a fair shake
anymore nick bosa with 14 sacks plus
2500
greg what'd we get this week this is a
pretty interesting board right here
obviously a really tight race
yeah yeah and what i need the audience
to do is tell me which comment you guys
are gonna like better
i'm about to hop into these comments
from people for people like you guys
that that that commented on this
they sent us their take and we're going
to vote and see which one we're going to
ride with let's start off with tony tony
kilos
he said uh nick bosa he's double teamed
almost every play conor and he's still
unstoppable this is a fact i'm an irish
fan i watch their games nick bosa is
always either double-teamed or he's
being held and he's still having an
impactful year connor he's in that plus
2500 crazy bro if he goes off one game
just imagine if he gets four sacks in
his next game
bro
that's great value i love this i love
this take right here but what's your
take on it the tan you feel nick bosa
this year the take is awesome number one
you guys are both right as niner fans
it's kind of crazy he's just not getting
enough love 14 sacks season which is
nuts right here plus 2500 odds those do
feel off to me now normally i would say
miles garrett is free money at plus 300
because he's been so good he's got 15
sacks you nailed the point greg the
voters just go by the numbers they're
not going to look at guys getting it's
wrong they're not going to look at guys
getting double-teamed they're not going
to look at guys doing the dirty work
you're going to go who had the most
sacks or who had the most pressures by
advanced data which is great there's
nothing wrong with that so right now
it's miles garrett you guys are both
right one big nick boasts a week and
he's going gonna be even more than plus
a thousand you might be looking at plus
600 plus 500 so
this thing's far from over i love this
take
all it that's all it takes is one week
that's all it takes is one week let's
move on to the next comment in s slim
shady 92 says aaron donald
is easily
the best value bet here
ah don't agree
i mean aaron donald it's good value i
mean it's decent value for aaron donald
but connor let's be real
you just mentioned nick bosa miles
garrett we even got parsons from the
calp there's just guys in front of aaron
donald that i think that have a chance
at actually winning than aaron donald
but what's your take are you in on air
donald is he is is that easily the best
value i'm not and aaron donald has been
the best defensive player in football
for almost the last decade right in
terms of best players in football it's
been him and brady for quite some time
that's how good aaron donald is and this
year
he's been great but there's just simply
been guys that have been better i look
at this strategy because we're talking
best value bet here right greg
value bet would be bosa you could
sprinkle hedge a little bit on it
another real bet absolutely miles
garrett at the top plus 300 is a lot of
money so you put a real bet on miles
garrett you put a sprinkle bet on bosa
as a hedge i think you'll come away with
the winner there people look at parsons
and say oh you know he's going to win
defensive rookie of the year and the
award system will look at that as enough
so i wouldn't get caught by the hype
there love aaron donald
just don't think anyone cares about him
as defensive player of the year right
now it's harsh to say it's dumb to say
as a football fan it's reality am i
crazy
no you're not crazy at all connor you're
actually preaching and i want people to
listen to you right now because my guy
just spit some fire on a sunday he is
preaching he said sprinkle on nick bosa
put some money down on miles garrett and
you're walking away a winner man i love
that uh
you're preaching to the choir right now
and let me uh see if the comments is
preaching to us connor i am in the
comments and i got landon landon is
rocking with micah parsons must be a
cowboy fan but now but michael parsons
is also volunteering he's awesome
michael parsons is also ballin as you
guys can see the comments are jumping on
my ipad uh
look at look at brandon is also usually
you guys see brandon talking about mike
micah parsons there goes the comments
jumping again
uh br betten's telling you to preach
connor
i'm i'm going to make a decision i i'm
going to i'm going to make a decision
we're going to call this a biased
decision and oh well it is what it is
it is what it is uh i just want to give
out some more hoodies i got isaac
boatman isaac boatman you were walking
away with a hoodie and aaron sham 45
says what is the man you're walking away
with hoodie but we're gonna make a
decision here connor
we're gonna go with my guy tony we're
gonna go with tony simply because he
mentioned nick bosa i'm a big nick bosa
fan and that's not the reason he's
getting the jersey but
his take was just better nick bosa has
better value than aaron donald connor
mentioned that and nick bosa has 14
sacks he's one game away i i strongly
feel he's one game away of of of of you
know making his case for defensive
player of the year so we're going to
rock with tony you're walking away with
a jersey i'm gonna send you a hoodie and
uh love your take brother love your take
greg we see these things flip all the
time you're right it takes one game it
takes one game aiden hutchinson had two
big games in college football and
flipped as the favorite to be the number
one overall pick went into the heisman
odds these pass rushers three sack games
it flips the odds keep an eye on bosa
keep an eye on of course miles garrett
and watt and even aaron donald out there
although it's tougher for those interior
defensive lineman all right moving on
prop segment we're not we're not getting
out of here without our prop segment you
got to tell us if it's either a lock or
if it's a drop
greg what props are we looking at this
week i think we're going to go on the
offensive side of the ball this week
okay you guys you guys let us know let
us know if it's a lot or if it's not i
need y'all to get in the comments
fill them things up y'all know what to
do let's get into it connor let's start
off with cornell patterson for dale
patterson to brush for over or under 48
and a half yards he leads atlanta in
rushing yards scrimmage yards and
touches and the falcons they've been
running the ball lately conor they've
been running the ball in the last three
games they had a 100 yard
uh rusher
so carter
is this
a lock is this a lock are we locking
this in or are we dropping it man is
cordell gonna go over
48 and a half against my niners i'm
gonna drop it uh with corduroy and i've
been a quarter out prop better this year
i just look for all purpose yards
because you never know what quarter l
you're gonna get and that's because the
falcons are trying to be obviously
unpredictable with him whether it's
going to be workhorse runner cordero or
it's going to be 10 target cordero and
if you go to the all-purpose yards you
give yourself some insurance there no
matter how high that number goes he's
been pretty good at hitting it now with
the rushing total 48 and a half is not a
lot here greg but the problem is
you know this your niners besides the
seattle game the last five weeks they
haven't allowed anything going on on the
ground the falcons are very predictable
uh it's a shame you know they they've
they have lost calvin ridley you know
kyle pitts teams are queuing in on him
and patterson and they've both still
been really good it's just tough against
a a rising defense right now so this is
one i traditionally stay away from i'm
gonna drop it
connor you're dropping it
and uh i i i don't dislike that because
like you mentioned the niners do
play the run well they play they they
stifle running backs when they usually
face up against the 49ers uh
but today i i see things happening a
little different conor i see things
happen a little different we're playing
against matt ryan who likes to throw the
ball historically against the niner he
slings he throws the ball we're
struggling that corner right now the
49ers are struggling at quarterback
the guys are dropping out like flies he
got first i mean draft picks out there
rookies out there so we're struggling
that cornerback
so i see the falcons coming out
throwing the ball with intentions to
throw in the ball connor and with that
being said that's gonna open up some
lanes
48 and a half isn't i mean it's not
crazy it's all it's it's a half a
century it's almost 100 yards but it's
not crazy this can happen in two rushes
two two twenty yards two 25 yard rushes
you know what i mean this can this can
happen easily so i i think i'm gonna
rock with
the over here i think i'm gonna rock
with the over i don't see cordell
patterson being a bell i don't see him
being uh you know a bell in this game or
or toting the rock 25 plus times but i
can see him getting 48 and a half yards
all right we got one more prop let's
knock it out
yeah let's move on karen let's move on
because i really like this one i like
this one a lot and i know you'll like
this one we got aaron rodgers to throw
over or under 271 and a half
passing yards connor he threw for 341
last week and four tubs let's not forget
it 10 touchdowns and no interception in
his past three games connor peep this
one he needs four touchdowns to pass
brett harv for first place on the
packers all times list he's gonna be
hungry he's gonna be hungry connor
yeah listen you're all over it you're on
it when there's a record in sight and
for a dude like rogers we've seen this
with brady those type of dudes uh they
see red they they lock in and let's not
forget here greg he's playing the ravens
who have lost everybody and as we were
prepping to do our show today jimmy
smith tested positive for covid so it's
like the onion headline right the man
that has lost all hope seemingly lost
hope he didn't even know he had the
ravens keep losing players that they
didn't even expect to start for them
this year so
the point is aaron rodgers is going to
come out and throw the ball around the
yard the only way he does not hit this
over which feels like the gimme of the
week is if they get too early of a lead
and just have to run out the clock so
over over over lock it in
connor is rocking with the over so am i
i bet on this ravens team uh last week i
bet them they covered i bet the money
line got it from you conor bet the money
line they did not win no they did cover
but one thing that's been
constant with the ravens this year is
people have been injured on their team
they've been dropping out like flies
that defense is injured hey aaron
rodgers
he's baker mayfield was throwing the
ball in the first half last last week
he's no aaron rodgers so go get 271 and
a half aaron i see that actually being
easy connor uh so i'm rocking witchy all
right moving on props looking good this
week i like rogers you're starting to
sell me on cp a little bit boldest bets
time you all know the do bond now greg
and i bring our boldest bets we're going
to ask the comments to get it done right
greg how are we feeling this week about
our boldest bets
feeling really good feeling really good
feeling real real real good about these
beds connor let's get some money uh
let's get right to it hold on before we
get to it i need everybody in the
comments you guys let me know if you're
riding with me you're riding with connor
we're gonna win this week we're gonna
get some plus money for you guys so
let's get right to it connor yeah came
close last week underdog parlay falcons
win ravens lose a tough one so the
parley only goes one to two no hit let's
bounce back this week let's go back to
the well of two touchdown scores gronk
against the saints two touchdowns that's
all you gotta know with gronk right now
gronk catches them in bunches if you're
gonna have the guts to bet on him to
catch one
bet on him to catch two he's done it
three times this year and i think every
game he's caught a touchdown he's caught
a second one now brady did not look good
against the saints when they played
earlier this year this is a defense that
he struggles against but let's be real
this is not the same saints team brady
gets angry coming off disappointing
performances against teams holds that
grudge looks to run it up bronx on the
field bet gronk two touchdowns plus 750.
those are
juicy juicy odds greg where are you
going this week
connor i love that connor uh
rob gronkowski's actually on my fantasy
team you mentioned earlier in the show
for the people that did not make their
fantasy playoffs
sorry for them feel sorry for me because
i did not make the playoffs but that is
okay connor that is okay had a busy busy
busy schedule this football season but
we're not making no excuses love that
play connor love that play but i threw a
curveball i threw a curveball at you
connor i threw a curveball at our
producers i threw a curveball at the
segment bowled his bets and also through
a curveball that everybody in the
comments because coming right now
is a lock i think that this was going to
hit i think that this one's going to be
easy we got russell wilson matthew
stafford to have over one and a half
passing touchdowns
in the game today we know what matt
stafford and sean mcvay has been cooking
up we know we know they've been hot
they've been cooking it up in la
but we also know what russell wilson
does and this is a deficit
division matchup conor
this is a division matchup we know what
russell wilson has been doing in this
division for the last i don't know how
many years and he's facing this rams
team a team that he faces constantly
every year
he does his fair share he does his fair
share of of of putting up numbers
against this rams team and i can i can
see it happening today all they have to
do is get two touchdowns each i can see
this happening so i'm gonna rock with
this i'm gonna rock with this mad
staffer russell wilson go get two
touchdowns man go get two touchdowns i
like you greg i think stafford knocks
this out for you in the first half you
just need for us to be able to throw uh
and this is a division game which means
it's going to be close which means that
he's going to have to at some point
throw the ball down the field seattle's
coaches need to let him do that so i
like to spec two touchdowns each is
nothing crazy at all so i love you
plus 170. this is awesome
this is a good find from greg here so we
need two things right now greg we need
the comments to let us know who they're
riding with and i think you still have a
giveaway in your pocket for this week's
show so let's get let's do that before
we get out of here
here we go here we go i am in the
comments man i'm in the comments and i
got a
big mic 13 says curveball greg curveball
shout out to you big mike 13. actually
i think that that's worthy of a jersey
oh sorry here we go uh my thing is a
little loose here i think that this is
worthy of a jersey because my guy just
threw the curveball at us through the
curveball that is mike big mike you're
walking away with a jersey as you guys
can see we're getting spammed by jj
snails rock and roll
that is not
that's not how you get a hoodie jj snow
uh
aspects 24 says almost almost
we're close uh
i mean i guess you were almost close to
getting the jersey so i'll give you a
hoodie i'll give you a hoodie for that
connor uh i'm just giving out take i'm
just giving a hoodie for takes now we
got distant thunder 88 jags going to
blow out the texans uh urban is free uh
giving you hoodie for that
connor i'm done i'm done giving out
these hoodies the people are rocking
with me they're rocking with you
is this vibes all around it's just good
vibes all around week 15 everyone's
feeling good we're at the finish line
here the squad ride is still rolling and
still gonna roll through the playoffs so
don't worry about that
that's a wrap everyone a huge
congratulations
to the winners shout out to aaron g
wales the squad ride title leader but
shout out to the lock legends that
challenged him marshall mcgaw tyler
carbone
and pro angler jb who always brings the
heat as well thank you to the commenters
if you want a hoodie don't worry br
betting is going to dm you within the
next 24 hours so with that being said
enjoy week 15 everybody i'm connor
rogers alongside greg ivory we'll catch
you same time same place next week
[Music]
you